. WE JUST NEED AN
AUTHOR IF SENATOR PORTANTINO IS
AVAILABLE OR ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GIPSON WE ARE READY TO GO. YEAH
.
THIS IS THE BASEMENT IF YOU
WANT YOU KNOW. I THINK WE CAN
BE WORKED OUT. NO WORDS REFER
MEMBERS I DO BELIEVE WE HAVE A
QUORUM PRESENT MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL LEYVA YOUR
LEYVA HERE WILK. WELL CARE
CHANGE CHAIN HERE THE RUSSELL
GLAZER MCGUIRE PAN PAN HERE. WE
HAVE A QUORUM SO WE WOULD
REALLY LOVE TO HAVE AN AUTHOR.
WHAT DO I HAVE. NO NO WE DON'T.
NUMBERS. WHO GIVES GOOD HERE.
YEAH IT. RIGHT
. TODAY'S HEARING
OF SENATE EDUCATION COMMITTEE
WE HAVE TWO BILLS ON TODAY'S
AGENDA SB SIX NINETY FIVE BY
SENATOR PORTANTINO AND AB NINE
A ONE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER GIPSON
WE ARE HEARING THESE ROLES
PURSUANT TO SENATE RULE TWENTY
NINE TEN BECAUSE THEY WERE
SUBSTANTIALLY AMENDED AFTER
THEY WERE INITIALLY HEARD.
CENTER PORTANTINO YOU MAKE IT
BEGIN. THANK YOU ARE MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS SB SIX NINETY
FIVE REQUIRES LOCAL EDUCATION
AGENCY TO PROVIDE A STUDENT.
PARENTS WITH A COPY OF THE
COMPLETED INDIVIDUAL EDUCATION
PLAN IEP. FOR THE EIGHT MOST
COMMONLY SPOKEN LANGUAGES IN
THAT DISTRICT WITHIN THIRTY
DAYS OF BEING REQUESTED AS WELL
IT REQUIRES THE I EP TO BE
TRANSLATED BY A QUALIFIED
TRANSLATOR THINK ABOUT BEING A
PARENT WHO DOESN'T SPEAK
ENGLISH. HAVE A SPECIAL NEEDS
CHILD THEY GET AN I. E. P. IT
COMES TO YOU IN ENGLISH HOW DO
YOU ENGAGE IN YOUR TRIAL THEM
WITH THE EDUCATORS. THIS IS A
COMMON SENSE BILL NECESSARY
THESE ARE KIDS THAT NEED OUR
HELP AND THIS BILL WILL HELP
THEIR FAMILIES. I HAVE FOLKS
WHO WANT TO SAY GOOD THINGS TOO
THANK YOU SENATOR PORTANTINO
THOSE IN SUPPORT PLEASE PROCEED
HER CHILD DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIA THE SENATOR I THINK
SAID AT PERFECTLY HOW CRITICAL
THIS YEAR'S FOR FAMILIES AND
PARENTS TO. HAVE BOTH THE EYE
PEAS AND THE MEETINGS IN THE
YEAR OR A LANGUAGE SO THAT THEY
UNDERSTAND THAT CAN MAKE A
IMPROVEMENTS AND ENSURE BETTER
OUTCOMES FOR THE CHILDREN THANK
YOU THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS IN
SUPPORT CHRIS RESPONSES. WHICH
CHIRLA THE COALITION FOR HUMANE
IMMIGRANT RIGHTS ARE PROBABLY A
SPONSOR. THANK YOU VERY MUCH TO
HAVE ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT. SEEING AND HEARING
NONE IS THERE ANY OPPOSITION TO
THE BILL. BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE. THE BILL HAS BEEN
MOVED DID YOU MISTER MAKE I
WANT MAKE COMMENTS PLEASE TO I
WANT TO THANK YOU FOR BRINGING
THIS FORWARD I'VE SUPPORTED A
SIMILAR MEASURE IN THE PAST
MYSELF I TO CHILDREN ONE WAS A
P. STUDENT ONE WITH SPECIAL
NEEDS IT IS TOUGH ENOUGH TO
NAVIGATE THAT PROCESS WHEN YOU
WERE AS SOPHISTICATED AS A
CONSUMER AS MY WIFE AND I. AND
I CAN'T EVEN CONCEIVE DOING IT
IF YOU WERE IN EMIGRATE AND AN
ENGLISH IS YOUR SECOND LANGUAGE
SO THIS IS NOT ONLY FOR THE
KIDS WHICH I AGREE BUT IT'S
ALSO FOR THE PARENTS AND I
THINK THIS IS I KNOW IT'S
EXPENSIVE BUT IT'S. IT'S
SOMETHING WE MUST USE SO THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MISTER VICE
CHAIR ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. THE BILL HAS BEEN
WHICH I TO CLOSE RESPECTFULLY
ASK WHEN I WROTE THANK YOU
SENATOR. THE BILL HAS BEEN
MOVED BY SENATOR PAM AND I'M
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ITEM ONE SB SIX NINETY FIVE THE
MOTION IS THAT THE ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS BE CONCURRED IN
LEYVA. LEYVA I WILL HI WILK I
CHIANG CHIANG I'D RUSSELL.
RUSSELL AYE GLAZER. GLAZER AYE
MCGUIRE HAND BY PAN AYE. THANK
THAT BILL HAS ENOUGH VOTES TO
GET OUT WE WILL WAIT FOR ONE
PERSON TO ADD ON THANK YOU.
CENTER FOR THE. ASSEMBLYMEMBER
GIPSON PLEASE COME FOR YOUR
TIMING IS PERFECT YOU ARE HERE
TO PRESENT AB NINE OH ONE OR TO
TALK TO US ABOUT IT YES THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING
ME TO PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL NOT
A ONE DUE TO THE RECENT
AMENDMENTS THIS BILL WAS REAR
FOR TO THE THROUGH THIS
COMMITTEE AS IT WAS HEADING TO
THE SENATE FLOOR HOWEVER I HOPE
TO CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE
STAKEHOLDERS ON IN THE INTERIM
TIME. TO HELP STRENGTHEN TO
MAKE THIS BILL BETTER BRING IT
BACK TO YOU. ASSEMBLYMEMBER
THANK YOU AND I HOPE THAT YOU
DO WORK ON IT BECAUSE IT'S A
REALLY GOOD BILL AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO HEARING IT NEXT
YEAR. LIKEWISE WE WILL YOU HAVE
MY COMMITMENT ON THE EXCELLENT.
WE DO NEED TO IT THOSE IN
SUPPORT. ANYONE IN OPPOSITION
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE.
WE HAVE A MOTION THANK YOU
SENATOR HANDER WE HAVE A MOTION
BEFORE US WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE RESPECTFULLY ASK WHEN I
VOTE THANK YOU SIR MA'AM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ITEM TWO EIGHTY NINE A ONE THE
MOTION IS THAT THE MEASURE BE
HELD IN COMMITTEE PURSUANT TO
SENATE RULE TWENTY NINE TEN
LEYVA. LEYVA I WILL THANK YOU
WILK AYE CHIANG CHIANG I'D
WRESTLE THE REST SO I GLAZER.
MCGUIRE PAN HI CAN I. VERY GOOD
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
THANK YOU TO OUR EDUCATION
COMMITTEE. AND WE ARE NOT QUITE
ADJOURNED BECAUSE WE'RE LET
PEOPLE AT ALL BUT YOU ALL VOTED
SO YOU CAN TAKE OUT. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. REPORTER
. PLEASE
STAY ON TO TURNED
. I SIX ZERO
MCGUIRE. OKAY THAT BILL IS OUT
SIX ZERO ITEM TWO EIGHTY NINE
NO ONE THE MOTION IS THAT THE
MEASURE BE HELD IN COMMITTEE
PURSUANT TO SENATE RULE TWENTY
NINE TEN WITH THE CHAIR VOTING
I VICE CHAIR VOTING I FIVE ZERO
GLAZER MCGUIRE THAT BILLS OUT
FIVE ZERO THANK YOU EVERYONE WE
NOW ARE OFFICIALLY. ADJOURNED
YOU